Ta-prohm isn't the most impressive ruin in
the world.
It's not even the most impressive in the neighborhood.
Angkor wat sits only a couple miles away -- it's
the largest religious monument ever built.
But Ta-Prohm is a bit more human scale. And
it has merged with nature
It's original name was Raja Vihara -- the
royal monastery -- and was dedicated to the
Buddhist personification of wisdom.
But it is a new place now, silk-cotton trees
and strangler figs have merged with the carved
rocks to create new structures.
The temple was built about 1000 years ago,
around 1186, just after Angkor wat, during
the golden age of the Khmer empire in what's
now Cambodia.
The Khmer controlled most of southeast Asia,
and the capital city Angkor was the biggest
urban center in the world before the industrial
revolution.
They had incredible technology to support
such a large congregation of humans for the
time.
Southeast Asia gets heavy rainfall in one
season, and less in another -- so the Khmer
built water management
Huge reservoirs, canals, channels and dikes
allowed them 3 harvests a year.
It might have been the best technology of
the time.
They built the temples at their peak. Khmer
empire ruler Jayavaraman VII, who also built
Angkor Thom nearby, is the man credited.
But a man's name doesn't really capture the
true size of the project.
About 2 or 300 years later, the society collapsed.
It wasn't all at once, or for one reason.
But a factor archeologists and ecologists
hypothesized was that the incredible water
management system failed
due to a change in the climate -- dire drought,
then heavy floods.
This possibility had been hypothesized before,
but a PHD student named Mary Beth Day spent
6 years digging
and found evidence for the theory in the form
of sediment records in the reservoir.
What also is sure is that the ruling class
moved south.
It's a beautiful place, but haunting: what
hundreds of thousands people would be living
here had it survived?
For around 400 or 500 years the forest merged
with Ta-prohm until it was 're-discovered'.
It should give us pause. Our civilization
is a collaboration with nature.
A giant structure must sway with the wind
and roll with the earthquakes, or else it
will surely, quietly, fall.
Hollywood films often depict the destruction
of urban centers.
But the crisis comes at once, so we can band
together to fight it.
In reality, giant cities have existed and
then died before. This one did.
It just takes time -- the rain falls, the
roots grow, and nature eats what we built.
The best technology of the time wasn't enough.